hello I'm professional DJ Cody Co and
this is my protege Dylan
Francis and we're here to find the real
DJ W W I'm a DJ I'm a DJ I'm a DJ I'm a
DJ I'm a DJ I'm a
DJ let's go down the line MH give give
us your real name and then your DJ name
my name is Roco aka DJ love Lake my name
is Gabriel aka DJ Meeks master Meeks
Master yeah it's to play on my last name
Meeks my name is Jade AKA J nicolay is
that your last name no it's my middle
name my middle name is Nicole but I
needed to make it sound like super you
know pizazzy okay okay cool my name is
Jess AKA rain girl rain girl my middle
name's Lorraine so you guys are all I
like the middle name derivative it's
almost as if you're copying with the
last person
dead what's up I'm Tommy also known as
DJ evil laugh you know I might H little
your middle name evil
laugh CJ evil laugh I got a
little you know hopefully that's a
recording cuz that one sucked oh yeah
yeah I got I got an audio thing I don't
do it
myself hi my name is Cassandra aka DJ
aie aie what's that mean the Sone word
for
fire do you guys like
music Love he laughed he did he did the
evil laugh you guys like music
he said I love it love music you love
music dude you have no idea what are
your DJ pet peeves when a drunk white
girl goes up to you and asks you to play
their friend song on Soundcloud it's not
even on Spotify oh my God very specific
I don't think I've had that one before
Mr Brightside The Killers okay I am so
sick of being asked to play Mr
Brightside by The Killers
every single gig it comes up at least
once when someone has their phone
requesting a song and they're like eight
miles in the crowd I can't see it so I'm
just like DJing like what yeah Okay Jade
did this she went ER she didn't do the
er er but she you know did the hand
gesture that's like the CL the classic
like cliche that you don't actually do
it's like you know like playing on vinyl
yeah when you show up to a bar and it's
a different setup than you're used to
and you're trying like you have 5
minutes before you're going on and
you're trying to figure out like that's
my pet peeve when my stuff doesn't work
at a place that I'm playing so okay I
think mine is probably like when you cut
the beat to have them sing along and
they don't and then you're like oh my
bad I'll just play yeah yeah forget it
that's what the
evil that's when you hit the evil
laugh when people that you're working
with don't have their equipment you know
I feel like people always come to the DJ
you know what my favorite track to play
is ever what subscribe to Jubilee it
goes off in the club subscribe to
Jubilee subscribe to Jubilee subscribe
to Jubilee subscribe to Jubilee I'm not
familiar with that I'm going to Shazam
it Shazam it subscribe to Jubilee
subscribe to
Jubilee oh it's called subscribe to
Jubilee I don't
know yeah yeah
sorry Jade sorry Jade damn sorry sorry
okay nothing personal niay Jade's name
actually stood out as suspicious to me
yeah same I feel like if you had to make
up a DJ name on the spot you would use
your middle name yeah it didn't Meeks
Master do that too wait didn't the whole
line of people do that yeah yeah his
name was actually evil
laugh
[Music]
all right so setting the scene they got
me DJ love like here in the building so
uh your boy got to turn it up for
show jub what
the what no this isn't Spotify I can't
just download stuff like this is Sado J
One 2 3 Let's
Go
Dr
the nice work very high energy supering
fast I think I if I were to take
anything out of the routine I would take
the machine gun shooting beats yeah it's
in the moment I'm going to digest that
fully and uh what what genre of music
were you playing uh Indie
IND DJ Meeks master all right okay hey
what's the
scene what up party people as we're
heading on further into the evening that
was just
Metallica now we're coming up with a
commonly requested song coming up next
we've got none other than Mr bright side
let's turn it
[Music]
up oh you
listen he
listen thank you thank
you oh what's
that DJ Meeks master that was fantastic
I also like that you were using the
tempo as the like a theramin
flute got to hit them with what they
don't see
coming rain girl let see what you got
it's a weekend half the group in the
crowd they like what I'm playing the
other half is there to get drunk and
listen to throwback
songs how are we all feeling tonight
everybody thank you Fu up hell yeah you
are I'm DJ rang girl thank you guys so
much for coming out tonight I know I've
been playing a lot of house and a lot of
dubstep music but this is a shout out to
the guy in the corner that wouldn't shut
the up about wanting
throwback
this one is for you D Let's Take a Shot
hey T Pain says it best let me buy you a
drink
everybody the song Cody listen to me
just play buy you a drink by T pay
you'll get the crowd back you dealt with
all of the things we threw at you very
well I felt like I was there thank you
guys yeah all right I got to sober up a
little bit Yeah sober up I think we
didn't get to actually really see yeah I
didn't really actually like absorb any
of I had to bring a bottle to you I was
drunk the whole time she killed it it
was a good show she killed it was a good
show next up DJ evil right all right all
right first off headphone placement you
know one ear off okay get a sometimes I
do a little head lean you know what I
mean no getting in there this is like
just paying the bills right a wedding
just paying the bills I see a
grandmother in the corner you know what
I mean she just had a hip replacement
she hasn't danc since Charles died you
know what I mean I'm like I'm you're
going to need another hip replacement
when I'm done okay I put on the Montel
Jordan all right you know the Walkers
are moving people are people are getting
out there you know it's like how
[Music]
we I'm like but I got a secret I got
something coming over
here I hit the beat repeat
right
out Granny's moving I'm like okay yeah
get in there
granny working I love
this that was good that was good a
little bit too much of the music coming
from the mouth rather than like seeing
the dejing part love that you were
actually also mixing songs
together all in one yeah right here we
go okay so I am playing at my residency
at Kahuna Tiki it's in North Hollywood
randomly sometimes we got like a big S
family in there so that's what's
happening thank you everyone so much for
coming my name is DJ aie we're going to
give a huge manuia to Rex talu for
winning his third fire knife
Championship out in LA everyone give me
a all right here we go all right here we
go she seems like she works at a at a
bar that is Hawaiian themed I think she
might be a bartender and it also sounded
like they were like Prize winner number
five yeah it seemed like they were doing
like trivia or something like that which
she could be a DJ with that yeah I don't
know and Uncle over there are going
crazy because there's always that drunk
uncle over there let's go Uncle Usos are
going crazy over there here we
go I don't know if it's him I why I
don't think he is I'm going to choose
[Music]
that I don't
know wait really you're really yeah
okay
nothing
personal
nothing thank you guys I see I I thought
you voting him out was wrong because he
just seems most like his name everything
seemed like love like is a is definitely
a DJ I DJ DJ but yeah no trust me I got
this What BPM do you guys usually play
at ooh round
dude thinking about that combined with
your like soft voice like
vo I want to see youring show I'd be
happy to show you I'm there I'm there we
know what What BPM I should be in you've
said house the whole time yeah super
house uh 124 to like 128 okay yeah I
start at like 120 and then could go up
to 130 down to 110 but you were playing
like hip-hop yeah that's what What BPM
is the the track you love so much this
is how we do it that's a little bit
slower that's more like 90 it is yeah
okay okay D it but the Benny Bazi is
quicker so you got to like ramp it up to
match Tempo you know what is Benny Basi
BPM at that's 120 oh okay
mhm is
it a little long it's a flag right there
yeah okay give us a good countdown
before the beat
drop all right
everybody
I love you I want to see you DJ even if
you're not a DJ I want to see you DJ are
you playing in a library no you got to
get up close to the mic you got to ASMR
that all right everybody all right
everybody three
two you didn't even say one yeah because
the moment they hear one they know it's
coming okay you got to hit them with it
slightly before then forgot about that
yeah I want him to be the DJ so bad I
want like I need him to perform so I can
buy tickets to a show yes cuz I would
love every second of it oh man when he
says all right guys all right everybody
I melt I melt so I'll do take it off
like by
Fisher and everyone's like okay and I'm
like all right guys 3 two 1 it's like
take it off and it like slow steady
undressed and everyone's like vibing
okay yeah I felt that I felt that I'm
hitting with a are you guys ready for a
throwback come on Make some noise I Ain
hearing it right now it's coming at you
5 4 3 2 if you want to go a
me hey must be the money okay thank
you um why are you guys DJs love love
love all right you know back in the day
people would compile a mixtape for their
sweet parts right I view DJing as doing
that for an entire crowd right to get
people where they're at and bring them
something new like
Prometheus that was awesome love you
yeah I love you what about me I love you
too for me DJing is about like mental
health so I I use like music a lot to
kind of like process my feelings and my
emotions and so I like to be able to
like be a person to do that for other
people too that's great I love being the
glue I like bringing people together and
just finding ways to get people from all
different types of society to just kind
of share a common moment and also
growing up like I had terrible taste in
music up until like Pandora came out and
then I was like it just opened up a
whole world of like wow I have all this
access like lime wire and then after
that I just kind of music became my
obsession and uh yeah I just tried to
hear every single genre after that
okay you're going to write the name of
who you think is the real DJ oh okay oh
wait were going to yeah what yeah who do
you think it is
then that's what I'm saying most
convincing
yeah
[Music]
yeah I don't actually believe that he's
a real DJ but I want him to
be all right so the person exit visiting
the square is
Tommy bye
Tommy if the person who is the real DJ
is still in the Square the lights will
turn green it's going to turn if they're
noted in the Square the lights will turn
red what if the first person we got
who yeah yeah it could
be
it was love
like I think it was can the real DJ
please step
forward what w I called it I called it
dude I'm I knew it oh my God yeah that
hurt yeah oh my cuz you went like this
but I was nudging you know trying to
beat I'm feeling disappointed in
ourselves uh I just can't believe we
failed so fast so fast and then spent
the rest of the time sussing out people
that just weren't even in just falling
up yeah yeah exactly okay tell us
about yourself well my name is Jay niay
I am a nightclub and Festival DJ and I
love it uh what music do you play so I
do EDM and Hip-Hop so I'm more so open
format I love it all nice honestly I'm
so hurt right now but I'm not even
surprised because I can't tell you how
many times I've shown up to a gig and
people don't even think I'm the DJ
they're like oh you're the dj I'm like
yeah I was why I got this backpack on me
like what my name isn't love like I just
pull out of my I'm an indie bedroom pop
musician okay so uh that's why you said
Indie I'll be real I read a Wikipedia
article about oh no we know we know
makes perfect sense yeah I'm still just
trying to find a way to monetize my
voice so y'all saying that y'all want to
hear me DJ radio just means the world to
me you should absolutely be a voice
actor for sure oh I'm believe you me I'm
trying oh there you go Hollywood CIS man
yeah so I'm not a real DJ um you like
house music though I love I love house
music big big house music yeah uh prep
wise I put on this
beanie I make comedy rap music with my
buddy evil f is my producer name thought
it was funny I have a small cultural
entertainment company I'm a polonian
dancer I could see you pulling from that
during the DJ set it was good yeah yeah
Jade we're sorry clearly shouldn't be
here judging CU or we shouldn't be DJs I
guess yeah I don't think we should be
DJs so we are retiring yeah Jubilee what
the is
up let's turn it
up
[Music]
it's getting
hot